[Music]
as an Obama has a new campaign ad and
it's trying to answer the question are
you better off than you were four years
ago
that's the question the Republicans have
been asking so he has an ad that answers
that
I watched the ad it just came out and I
have to say Obama makes a pretty
convincing case that the answer is yes
check this out I'm Barack Obama and I
approve this message
he keeps saying it this president cannot
tell us that you're better off today
than when he took office well here's
where we were in 2008 worst financial
collapse since the Great Depression
American workers were laid off in
numbers not seen in over three decades
shore has become a major ratings magnet
that promises to return for a second
season that here's where we are today
the Dow soared 244 points the sixth
season of Jersey Shore will be the last
one an executive producer announced the
fifth season will be four boxes
not going back we are moving forward
Barack Obama he killed bin Laden and
Jersey Shore
[Applause]
you